[Music]
oh
[Music]
and now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
[Music]
ah hey there boys good to see you again
what can i do you for thanks mr
macarthur well you can start by giving
us everything in the cash register well
golly is that a firearm you're pointing
at me there yeah yeah you knew it i'm
very disappointed in you boys we don't
care empty it out yeah yeah
get out man oh i suppose boys will be
boys i'm going to have to call the
sheriff you know but you've got me for
now go ahead take everything thanks mr
mcarthur thanks pistol whip him oh all
right now that's one for you that's one
for you go ahead take some bazooka joe
and get out of here you rascals oh those
boys what pickle will they find
themselves in next stay tuned for next
week's installment of adventures of the
white privilege boys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
strange
[Music]
boy those wiegers sure are doing well
they are yeah they get the light the
flame and they're good figures since
we're working now since we're
technically a part of the media that we
should uh also uh propagandize you
carrying water so we have senator ted
cruz in the show today boom big show
nice senator ted cruz so i'm gonna turn
this down i hear my headphones it's just
myself i think it's i think ted cruz on
the show is going to be talking about
what's been going on with gofundme and
the freedom convoy in canada and what
these states are going to be doing to uh
to
hopefully you know uh help us avoid a
communist hellscape
and also we'll be talking about china
look gerald and i disagreed about this
where i don't think the united states
should even be participating right in
the communist chinese olympics gerald
thinks we should i understand the idea
of engaging but
this is a little bit different for
example in world war ii because right
now we have a complicit united states
media and corporations who are actively
doing the bidding of the communist
chinese party and so i think that's a
that's a different problem than sending
a jesse owens that's a different problem
than having joe lewis speed of max
schmeling i think we're at a different
point in history and we need to look we
could crush china right now and i mean
the communist chinese party in order to
help liberate the chinese people and
instead you know the rock john cena
coca-cola uh the united
as well no they don't st them no
they're barely there oh send them back
how many weaves do you need
so uh we'll be talking about and you
know what comment before we get to
anything else comment below
should we even be taking part in these
olympics and uh we'll get to some of the
propaganda that's been taking place and
nbc has been carrying the water along
with joe biden uh not knowing anything
about uh uh fire oh sorry weapons of war
he calls them
the mace so we'll have a lot to get to
and as you know stuff has been going on
with spotify with joe rogan and before
that youtube so if this show is not on
youtube for some reason especially when
we talk about china today
uh we're no longer on youtube it's
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
10 a.m eastern you can watch it on
rumble you can subscribe at mug club we
have another full hour of show today
we'll have an extended interview with
ted cruz just tune in because you won't
find us if you search and uh hit that
like button right now that's a good
thing you can do for youtube algorithms
um one f so before i go on there you go
smash it smash it
nine i'm gonna take a breath
gerald hey how are you i'm well it feels
good to hit the like button doesn't it
it does it really does it's cathartic
it's helpful sometimes it feels good to
hit the dislike button but you can't do
that anymore not anymore how are you sir
i'm okay you're okay i'm okay i didn't
sleep that's okay yeah i go through like
i sleep really well and then i'm like my
body says that's enough sleep for two
days was a clown gonna get you again
yeah uh okay yeah clowns are then of
course you can't do it i don't know why
we have clowns with children and when
people act like it's an irrational fear
it is a giant scary disproportional
beast with colors that in nature
signifies aggression when you ever see
an animal with bright red bright yellow
that's usually when they lift their
claws or their belly to say this is
poisonous and we send that into a
children's party clown the point is i
would like to see a clown genocide and
uh he is here oh no you love him in
china no clowns matter uh i'll be on
tour with him we just added a show april
16th the second show added in uh well
detroit royal oak michigan royal oak
theater right around detroit and uh now
tickets are on sale june 18th in pikes
peak colorado lottery.com tour
uh dave landau how are you ahoy uh i was
good until you uh you do know that i'm
the president of the clown defamation
league ah right but it's more of a piero
it's more of an artistic clown well yeah
yeah it's a clown who has three acts
correct yeah and no one laughs because
that would be well no it's it's it's
definitely showmanship yes it's a little
bit of showmanship it's not terrorizing
children no people get mis people think
we do but we don't no no i do
right but not everyone right well that's
also because once you have them sign the
release form you i don't know
you know you kind of know what you're in
for you signed up for this like i didn't
know that that was what i was signing
hey speaking of uh assigning we signed
on of course uh to corporate overlords
we have no choice to promote
black history month here at louder with
crowder we got his black history
[Music]
boom
all right so jumping off with the first
black history month fact we're going to
bring new information to you guys in
1975 lee elder was the first
african-american to play in the masters
and then larry elder was hit with a
banana pie well by a gorilla suit person
yes yeah that's not no it's not racist
not at all all right another black uh
history month fact there dave uh in 1983
uh gooey on just pick a name it's normal
in 1983 guion s bluford became the first
black american to go into space wow
well we knew it wouldn't be deep-sea
diving well no
in 2017
timothy jacksonite was recorded as the
first black father to actually return
home after going to the store for
cigarettes so that's nice progress yeah
this has been lot of craters black
history month we got
there you go
uh before we move on here to uh the
second amendment issue that uh joe biden
just
uh okay i just i i can't even you know
you guys can go in and well you can't
search but if you go to
elitistcredit.com search steven
crowder's second amendment you will see
this argument that joe biden brings up
is one of the most rudimentary arguments
that you've heard you probably heard it
yeah in you know philosophy class 101
and he's still using it kind of like the
77 cents on the dollar for you know for
women when they talk about women's
rights women in the workplace so we'll
get to it i know it seems remedial but
it just he gave us a layup but before
that speaking of layups did you see this
there isn't colbert
i have not i'm excited though yeah so
colbert you are
yeah i've
stephan colbert
uh put out this sketch yesterday
uh and i don't want to say low hanging
fruit
but um
i mean steve stephen goldberg hanging
fruit in his writing staff yes
those are those are those are high bush
fruits
yeah oh jeez it's the wild variety and
we're canceled
a sketch mocking
taking a risk huh
rudy giuliani here you go if you liked
rudy giuliani on the masked singer
you'll love him on naked and seditious
traitor island a nude giuliani flown to
an uninhabited island and then we leave
him there that's it that's the show what
will happen will he succumb to the
elements or end up covered in poisonous
snakes desperately crying out to god to
end his suffering will the wild boar
take an amorous interest don't know
don't care in fact we're not even
sending cameras because this isn't
actually a show just something we did
and thought you might enjoy
no food no shelter no wine
naked and seditious trader island and
coming soon to fox the floor is actual
lava stirring ted cruz
um wow
well they did it hey you know what by
the way i don't know if we can thank you
guys there in the country in our edit
bay
for for so much less money doing better
jobs at the photoshops and sketches and
far fewer people far far fewer people by
the way was that a was that a death
threat that was just saying we'll kill
rudy julian and i don't care i get that
it's a joke but keep in mind they went
after sarah palin for having a map that
had targets saying these are the
districts to target they went after
marjory taylor green they've gone after
yours truly claiming that these are
death threats when we have joked you
know for example about i don't know
maybe it might have been like throwing
kamala harris at a plate class window
which of course i would never do right
just a joke
but that's all that was yeah
is there is there no warning there is a
immediate information nothing at all has
he been charged with sedition by the way
i was just curious i just wanted to make
sure the seditious thing that they're
putting on there saying that he is a
traitor and that he has basically tried
to overthrow the united states
government instead of challenge the
legitimacy of an election that was fully
fair
history that we've ever seen i believe
really said that it was the safest and
most fair election and i know history
despite the fact that people were were
you know there were so many [ __ ] in the
ballot boxes well mr giuliani your face
is running down we can see actual hair
dye well that's just for minutes just
for me oh well oh that's a weird look
what did you think about the cold oh i
think it's brilliant writing okay
what do you have a staff of 50 on that
are we are we having a guest on later
who was just lit on fire on that show
yeah well yeah look if the floor is lava
you're supposed to not be on the floor
anymore that's the whole point of the
game that's true that just needs to be
quicker watch their next sketch is going
to be why we need to do it with a
filibuster
we don't like the filibuster we
shouldn't have it and then colbert comes
back
applause sign naked and afraid the
supreme court edition have you seen the
dancing pfizer needles
[Music]
come on five more emmys we'll bring them
back how many writers does it take to
just come up with the worst sketch is
the and horrible photoshop well when
they're unqualified diversity hires it's
a little bit more time yeah that's true
who's the head writer who's like that's
really good writing oh i don't think the
head writer speaks english
it was a stand-in for the pirate from uh
captain phillips no he was selling hot
dogs outside of the building where they
film that show where are you from are
you from oh mozambique have you ever
thought about writing comedy yeah oh
you're a funny guy good for you you're
qualified when you use androgynous
you're genderqueer even better you could
be a senior writing position yeah no no
pakistanis work for us i don't know what
your problem with them is but you're
welcome in right yeah just you're right
come on in here we'll give you a job
in 2015 the atlantic wrote this stephen
colbert's readings to death 17 men two
women and all 19 of the late show's
writers are white so
ah no wonder they well that changed yeah
definitely changed yeah
that was 2015.
do you know do you know look do you know
why it's not that women are incapable of
being funny let me just address this
argument off the bat there are some
really funny female comments kathleen
madigan one of my favorite of all time
uh joan rivers you'd be hard pressed to
find anyone who says that she isn't
funny
men have to be funny right that's how
men interact with each other if you hang
around men you will see that they
interact very differently than women and
if you go to an open mic more men are
obviously applying to an open mic
locally so let's say there's 10 slots in
an open mic what they now say is look
there are 10 slots and uh eight of them
are men and two of them are women yeah
but there maybe were 40 people who
applied and 35 of them were men and when
you say they have to be five and five
guess what you're drawing from a
shallower talent pool just like
affirmative action just like quotas when
you're talking about university and
women who shouldn't make it to the top
get to the top it's not their fault when
you watch all these female comedians
that they're unfunny it's like a kid
who's never been spanked yeah well this
is how we get women
we have to be funny for them to like us
because we're smelly brutes yes 22
writers on stephen colbert's writing
stuff this is from 2020 and here's the
head writer is it howard stern ariel
dumas ariel dumbass ariel johnson dumas
sorry sorry dumas all right well we'll
do a little bit of research and i bet
you her tweets are pithy oh i bet i bet
you they have an agenda behind them yeah
i can't maybe i think there's and that
agenda is comedy me thinks there's a
[ __ ] hat somewhere in her timeline
resist is there an applause sign on
twitter as well or i wish we had an
applause sign i feel better about it
right now um so i just hated that i
don't know what else do you say to it
well um you said all you could say yeah
i'm trying to think what else is funny
let's kill him
let's throw rudy giuliani out of a
helicopter right yeah and have him die
in the woods remember the the the guy
911 guy who made the city better who
also was times person of the year and
like yeah but so was hitler well yeah
okay for different reasons yeah
i understand he was man of the year
because he brought the whole country
together anyway the point is it doesn't
matter and safest most secure election
in history so let's move on to someone
who does know what they're talking about
of course not former mayor rudy giuliani
um there is of course uh 40-year high
inflation we have a decimated southern
border we have this unbelievable power
struggle with china uh but uh don't
worry the former vice president biden
has a plan it brings us to this week in
biden if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black i don't want to get going
because i have to keep you here too long
because you know all i'm about what i've
said and you know what i've done and you
know what we're doing and you know i
know what you're doing let me close with
this
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black
perfect
are they putting tongue twisters on his
prompter i just think they
just have to give him a giant spoonful
of peanut butter before they send him
out there
i was going to talk about international
but how much wood
would a woodchuck chuck yeah if a wood
chuck could come on you know you know
there's there's you know the thing with
the wood they got those teeth come on
what are we what are we doing can i get
you what's up what's the medicines that
cause uh dry mouth before i go out i
promise all the medicines
hold on make me [ __ ] my pants
it's a lesser of evils at this point
it's all evil i could keep you here all
day if i know what we were talking about
if i could string a sentence together i
love that he started with that you know
but i know
you know that they know that i know that
we know and he knows they're saying that
i'm a paranoid schizophrenic but that's
only because they know
that i know that they know that i'm
watching me sometimes when i'm in the
bathroom
and i run out of the toilet paper i like
to pretend that that
i'm like a captain out on the ocean yeah
with the toilet paper rolls yeah hey hey
look out and i see someone i said is
that a there's a siren and i can't
resist cameras it's the same chill loose
joe
doesn't like it zamala's watching me
hello all right joe lewis joe lewis
place hold on one second
oh oh no go on
he doesn't like it ever since we played
with nerf guns no he doesn't well the
moment that we acted like you were like
fine leave he's like well i guess i'll
stay yeah he's playing hard to get he is
all right so speaking of nerf guns uh
last week joe biden traveled in new york
city to speak about uh well you would
think he'd be speaking about you know
rapid rapidly rising crime rates of
course and oh i thought
well police
members sorry can we say policemen
police zs leaving the force in record
numbers leaving their uh citizens
exposed which by the way you're not
supposed to have a gun because you're
supposed to call the police but they're
racist the point is you're trying to
make sense if it doesn't make sense he
was supposed to talk about violence and
instead he talked about specifically gun
violence and the second amendment and he
said something so asinine uh
we'll see if you can catch it
for any of the press any depressed
listing this doesn't violate anybody's
second amendment right okay there's no
violation of a second amendment right we
talk like there's no amendment it's
absolute when the amendment was passed
it didn't say anybody can own a gun and
any kind of gun and any kind of weapon
you couldn't buy a cannon
and when the this this uh amendment was
passed
no reason why should be able to buy
certain assault weapons but that's
another issue okay first off uh joe
biden
this is how we feel everyone in this
room
is now dumber for having listened to it
god have mercy on your soul now i want
you to comment below can you see where
he literally used in his argument what
would already be the counter argument
before i present it to you if you're
familiar with me having discussed this
topic
do you got it he brought up cannons look
he says that didn't say that you could
have a cannons that's actually exactly
what the second amendment says not only
is it exactly what the second amendment
says it was reinforced where there was a
question sent to james madison i don't
know if you remember james mason one of
the one of the leaders of that that
whole bill ah yeah they said hey you
know we're dealing with some uh pirates
and stuff can we have cannons and it was
like [ __ ] yeah you can have cannons let
me read you this
have two firearms
muskets and cannons right yeah there's
more than that but the point is he's
trying to say he couldn't have cannons
look there's a letter of mark 1812 james
madison gave permission to a privately
owned ship to have mounted cannons it
says i have commissioned the private
armed brig called the prince nephew
nef chatel mounting 18 carriage guns
hereby authorizing nicholas millen of
the said break to subdue seas and take
any armed or unarmed british vessel
public or private which shall be found
within the jurisdiction
jurisdictional limits of the united
states this is the same guy who wrote
the bill of rights he was asked can we
have cannons the guy
james madison if you read the actual
letter all references available at
loudersguider.com was almost confused
kind of like sometimes when we get
questions in chat it's like so stephen
do you uh do you uh like uh you know uh
do you like ice cream well yeah like you
don't already know why are you wasting
my time with this question james madison
was like can we have canon she's like
why are you
did you read it
did you read it of course you can have
cannons second amendment why would why
would you not be able to have cannons
dummy that was the letter that he wrote
i love it i love it what are you gonna
do go out and take a british ship with a
musket
you're gonna shoot the wood and it
bounces off hey guys stop there were
other weapons too you're talking about
there was the puckle gun there was a
jiren dhoni air rifle there was the
pepper box revolver the belt and
flintlock these were all around the
founding fathers knew about them they
certainly knew about cannons that was
the most powerful weapon that you could
really have back then and they said of
course you can have cannons which
actually if you're talking about
expanding that right if you're talking
about changing the scope how do you
apply it today okay what would be the
equivalent today of cannons at least
tanks so my point is for you to think
that it only applies
to an old lever action or pump action
shotgun which by the way is also uh
something that should be banned
according to former vice president joe
biden he just doesn't realize that he
said it
of course cannons yes
it was a letter of exasperation from
james madison like don't waste my time
yes yes you can have cannons well and i
have i have an idea joe biden you said
that no amendment i guess can't be
changed or whatever you said yeah
there's there's a process for that and
it's not going through congress right
it's going through the states so if you
really feel like the second amendment
should be taken out why don't you go
through the process yeah that's not what
you're that's because he fell he fell
asleep halfway through explanation well
he's like the problem i can't be
expected to listen to all these phrases
huh don't know what to do i'm not
retired don't get me going even though
i'm 92. to sleep gosh a man who should
be well past retirement and social
security age who's never worked in the
private sector running the entire
country who could possibly have foreseen
this going badly now here's him also
using his anti-gun rhetoric um when
discussing an nypd officer
and here's the thing listen to what he
says this just shows you how little
these people know now you should have
been able to understand that joe biden
knows nothing about firearms when he
told his wife to just take a
double-barreled shotgun and fire it into
the air a crime illegally
i tell my wife she needs to protect your
home coco and a felony why did that
happen were they at a ghetto picnic yeah
effectively i don't know it was a gender
reveal party at a barbecue
so this is what he said when discussing
an nypd officer who was shot see if you
can spot just how dumb
he is in a specific instance it's really
a weapon of war
one of the things i was proudest of
years ago when i was in the senate i was
able to
get these uh weapons uh and the weapon
of war magazines outlawed that got
changed it got overruled but i don't see
any rationale why
there should be such a
weapon able to be purchased
violated anybody's second amendment
rights to deny that opposition
but anyway their futures were cut short
by a man of stolen glocken
at 40 round magazine and yes
a weapon of war is the most popular
sidearm in the country a glock i think
he said glocken he said glocken
i'm doing the german pronunciation
glockensize and margin and he said 40
round weapon there was a drum magazine
in that block i believe he used the word
stolen yes yeah change it wasn't
properly acquired it means yeah it
wasn't legal you gotta close this
stealing loophole yeah people shouldn't
be allowed to steal also people
shouldn't be allowed to throw their guns
in a dumpster by a grade school like
your son [ __ ] well i thought it was
let's not focus
weapon of war a glock a glock which is
the most common handgun that and by the
way just a semi-automatic handgun weapon
of war which would
i say hey guys yeah come get it i said
no more weapons of war that's the
walther very similar to the glock no
more weapons of war in the studios guys
we have to make sure that uh we don't
want any weapons of work gerald
uh jailed yeah jailed but no i just i
want to it's not a yeah it's a no look
it's a walther sidearm you can take joe
lewis with you there uh uh good soldier
how am i gonna protect no more weapons
of war in this oh my oh my god oh my god
there's a weapon of war on me here oh no
i'm gonna keep that weapon of war yeah
you're gonna have to
it's not quite a cannon did we cut my
penis out of the montage
[Laughter]
thank you nobody came in it does have
kind of a drum magazine it does
the refractory period i don't know if
it's a good thing right
this is what you guys need to know right
he says ah you can't have cannons yes
you absolutely can't have cannons
there's a historical context for that he
says weapons of work lock that's your
that's your gun that's almost every
single pistol in the country walther
glock hk the most popular guns in the
country he's now considered weapons of
war so when you next hear about the
assault weapons ban according to joe
biden former vice president joe biden
a glock
is a weapon of war if that's a weapon of
war then everything is a weapon of war
and you're not entitled to a weapon of
war the only people entitled to a weapon
of war is uh the military the fbi of
course who we are beyond uh trustworthy
and a local police force who are
systematically racist
well any weapon can be a weapon of war
right
i've seen chuck norris use a chair i've
seen palestinians use rocks steven
seagal uses his fists as weapons
actually he uses open hands the chops
cause if you use your fists you can't do
the fake slapping
that's true
it's like oh he must be striking
everything yeah he's just hitting
himself he's hitting his fat meaty self
at golden corel his mouth is a weapon
you're like stephen just get more salads
stop doing that every time you go to the
salad bar i slap my tits
bad things happen yes
what are we going to run out of
production rice on my plate yes because
chocolate fountain was the first
caucasian to open up a dojo in japan no
you married someone whose father had a
dojo and retired and then you married
kelly lebrock while you were married to
her you piece of crap hey
i'm a bigamist so
i have swollen purple feet yes and
nipples now he used the exact same
language former vice president joe biden
last year uh when he called for banning
again weapons of war but he was called
for calling for banning assault rifles
now
i know this has been a hobby horse of
mine for a long time
got it done once
we should also ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines in this country
there's no reason someone needs a weapon
of war with 100 rounds 100 bullets then
a hoop and stick that can be fired
from that weapon
okay so first off he said assault weapon
assault rifle is a term that's often
used in the military meaning like burst
fire assault weapon doesn't mean
anything that's where you can put
anything under that umbrella like a
glock is a weapon of war assault weapon
is a made up term this is legal pistol
grip is illegal we've been through this
i know it's remedial but it's just
important to see
the winds that are picking up here okay
can you feel the winds changing this guy
now thinks for some reason he's going to
be able to push through some kind of
anti-gun legislation it won't be done in
a constitutional fashion because it's
immensely unfortunate so he needs to
make sure that people who know nothing
about firearms hear glock go oh my gosh
you mean that weapon of war just don't
be stupid don't be silly the way that
you convince people in your life okay
because we try to be solution oriented i
did change my mind where we took people
to the range they fired walters they
fired shotguns just take someone you
know who's never shot a firearm take
them take them to the range have them
fire a walther if they have a glock have
them fire a glock then explain to them
this is what the former vice president
wants to ban as a weapon of war they'll
go oh
oh now i know it's [ __ ] there you go
your wife can't protect herself because
a handgun is no longer allowed right
some other weapons of war like you said
by the way to include is the beretta m9
the mossberg 500 shotgun just to be
clear that's a pump shotgun uh k-bar
knives and rocks
these are weapons of war
well k-mart it's like listen come on if
you're just going to say weapon of war
anything everything goes under that well
that's why possible anything you can use
yes
an assault rifle is anything you just
rob a liquor store with a rifle it's an
assault rifle just the dumbest argument
that i've ever heard and i think joe
biden is playing to his base a little
bit here and he's trying he's losing in
so many areas he's like well i guess
i'll go back to this is beto available
to go out and be my czar well that's why
he uses words and he doesn't show people
because he wants you know i don't think
anyone's going to see someone out there
harpoon fishing and think you in the
navy no they're not going to yeah
because they know okay it's just a
harpoon gun so he wants it he wants to
tell you they have these harpoon guns it
should be only in the you know they
should only be with the village people
weapon of war the best thing to use to
sell an agenda is biden's words yes well
yeah don't get him started though dave
don't get him going bad in his weapon of
war
where am i and that and those luscious
locks did you notice that he tried to
dye them blonde recently yeah like we
would be able to tell
it doesn't work it just shows up one day
it's like oh yeah joe biden he's always
been blonde yeah it's just as i was
saying
well he's got a stutter that's the whole
problem you can't make fun of him now
he's right it's a sweater yeah it's a
stutter yeah he's too old it has that
look like a dog peed on them yeah you
know like they look like a dog's crotch
yeah yeah yeah like one of those dogs
that doesn't or like the eye goop
little bichon dogs yeah like you know
like an old dying man would have yes
exactly yeah who's trying to trick you
in the thing that he's not dying like
yeah in other words they're like you
know what i'm sorry uh mrs biden your
husband's probably not going to make it
and then he's like what if i can get the
guy he's like i'm doing better i'm
looking i'm not dead yet i'm very fresh
yeah here's a bunch of videos of me
saying uh the n-word in perfect horrible
context i feel like i could take on the
world yeah
by the way next time they do a press
conference make sure joe biden isn't
looking directly into the sun the like
squinting barely able to see is not a
good look just leave sunglasses on them
yeah yeah aviators all the time like
stevie just just
wonder charles comes out in a bomber
jacket
just put a piano in front of him and
just have him blind piano the rest of
his presidency
what do you think he's doing now dave
well that's true have him read his
speeches in braille yes
i think if i get going
i love oh crap that's a song
hey by the way oh i say get rid of us
all rivals that's what
if uh if you guys are watching right now
on youtube of course we're also
available on spotify still we're
available on android we're available on
apple so you guys can listen to the
audio version and sometimes there's some
uh some easter eggs in there that we
don't necessarily have here on the uh on
the show on youtube and rumble okay
so uh it's time to get to the um you
know the uh some people call them the
the beijing olympics i call them the
peaking genocide olympics but it's
whatever you want to call it
it doesn't roll off the tongue yeah uh
when do they change when did they become
the beijing thing
it's sort of like uh is it uh mumbai
bombay
what they changed the name didn't they a
bit of beijing yeah
maybe i don't know long time ago i don't
know if it's beijing or peaking the
point is i don't care it's either one's
duck i don't like
no idea that we have anything to do
right now with china in the capacity
that we do i know you disagree you think
we should go to the olympics yeah
absolutely do not because
of course not every unless they're in
north korea well i'm going to make my
case system okay fine okay and i
understand where you're coming from you
do but you're wrong
so uh first off let me set the stage
remember when president donald trump
said this
biden is a puppet for china
son walked out with 1.5 billion i think
it's a little bit
allowing them to rip off america for
many years and by the way he wasn't the
only one who was echoed by this um
geopolitical analysis or correspondent
in china himself donald trump don't
trust china china is home i mean that's
the thing cnn could learn from that
brevity fantastic it does you don't need
to be so long-winded i heard everything
i need to know we trust him he's news
it's true
you talk about the flag
well china's been ripping us off for a
long time okay china you can't trust
china they have small heads
small feet they tie them up they bind
them
the feet
it's sick folks it's sick
[Laughter]
he's the you know what if nothing else
you've got to give credit to president
donald trump everyone was saying china's
going to be the next great superpower of
the world and donald trump said uh not
on my watch and it's a rolex
by the way
submariner yes
not on my
ten thousand dollar breitling okay
i love the dig though at hunter he's
like they walked away with 1.5 billion
and it's like yeah
do you know how smart this guy isn't
he's not walking away with 1.5 billion
for anything unless it's illegal
no of course there's no way you get it
yeah
especially the chinese who are you know
these people are pretty business savvy
they didn't go like
pro con let's make a pro and con list
okay pro hunter biden um khan smoke
crack smoke palm have sex with niece
sexual assaulter and frog and dumpster
but we went good and bad
rhett should give giuliani to the wrap
top yeah let's give him a good job
he'll end up in a forest on colbert
so
um these are it's just chinese
propaganda we talked with you about the
very fetching um and now victoria's
secret model for their new chinese foot
binders with juicy written across in
victoria's secret uh formerly american
should never be allowed back in the
country
eileen goo who defected became a
communist chinese uh citizen just won
her first goal yesterday giving china of
course a huge propaganda win we all wait
with baited breath
eileen goo
then the third and final run is 94.
there's they must be so proud former
american there is so much online uh
online commotion about it they actually
crashed weibo oh really just china's
version of facebook yeah which is just a
funny name
well
to us
for them does it mean anything in
chinese why you ask webo what does it
mean web probably
so this is this is one of those things
they're claiming or is one of their own
she defected from the united states she
trained in the united states then went
and she is performing uh you know at the
olympics for china and the media doesn't
just here's the problem the media
doesn't dress like by the way she was
american up until uh um well yesterday
and uh now she's competing for communist
china and she says that there are
there's more opportunity in china and uh
isn't this great isn't this a wonderful
victory for china first off any victory
for china is now
it's not wonderful for anybody it's
actually it's a loss for the world right
and she wanted to inspire young women
i'm like yeah all five they let live yes
right you want one of them to be a skier
is that what you're saying and i have
twins so i've been having to get you
know his and her everything i don't know
if there's like you know baby bathtubs
in china there's a uh his bathtub that's
a little bigger bathtub yeah and uh her
bathtub is just like a giant goldfish
bag that you can put them in yeah yeah
you actually it comes with a return
label yes and send it back to the
company yeah they have a nice aquarium
there it's just skeletons of kids yeah
by the way i don't i know everybody's
just saying oh see they're clapping
they're happy it's wonderful that former
tennis star i don't know if you saw this
too but peng shui she was even planted
in the stands to actually cheer on gu as
she won that's how i decorated my living
room everything is totally
yeah everything's totally fine i don't
know if you remember that this was the
person who basically accused one of the
chinese communist party leaders of
sexual assault uh she disappeared for a
while and went to i guess a re-education
camp because she came back and said oh i
never actually said that these guys are
fantastic she was being sexually
assaulted right then there was actually
a chinese official with his hand up her
rear going well clap clap clap i think i
think they just send you to a place for
more sexual assault yeah right you think
that was sexual assault i'm going to
show you section right it's like when
your dad catches you smoking he makes
you smoke a whole pack of cigarettes
right exactly yeah but it's like dear
leader in north korea and everybody's
like clapping and falling down in awe of
their god walking down the street and
then if you pan to the left it's guys
with guns on them you know what i mean
so like this isn't real and then the
media just goes of course uh chinese
tennis star peng shui there cheering on
her teammates like no she's about to die
yeah
her family is being held
somewhere until she applies that's my
problem is it's different because at
least back when you're talking about joe
lewis max schmeling you know when you're
talking about uh i just forgot the name
of the runner uh jesse owens jesse owens
america was cheering for them and the
media was very straightforward about
okay teams good bad we're hoping for a
win for the good guys right and i know
that there's a little bit more to it
than that but now you have the media
doing the bidding of china you have
corporations who by the way will boycott
georgia
because they don't believe that you
should have an abortion after the baby
has a heartbeat and its own dna they'll
boycott georgia but they will is in
kindergarten right and they will they
will plaster their name across the
skating rink in china where they uh are
actually committing mass genocide but
system of a down has written a song
about that yet so you know what we just
said oh we'll get there come on and uh
this is also funny when you talk about
pandering speaking of the chinese
uyghurs spelt
y g h you are okay in the comment
section i don't want you making any
little little comments jokes i know i i
agree i have my i'm just saying i
usually there's no more there's no more
no eminem jokes here no no vanilla ice
jokes uyghurs it's a serious problem but
anyways the uyghurs um have been of
course you know abused uh these are
muslims in china rose who have been
completely
tortured locked away uh of course uh
stripped of their rights so what did
they do they had a uyghur muslim skier
light the torch at opening ceremonies
and watch the media cover uh what a
victory this is today is cynical some
might even say sickening move by the
chinese government during its highly
choreographed opening ceremony beijing
gave the honor of being one of the two
athletes to light the olympic torch to a
member of the oppressed uyghur mining
good for
china's far west region an ethnic
minority the chinese government is right
now committing genocide against good for
jake tapper i'm glad we found that clip
he actually called the balls and strikes
and he's dead
yeah and he's been fired from he's
disappeared sad suicide today they just
you know they were and they weren't
expecting just even jake tapper they
weren't expecting anyone like hey you
know we're good with wiggles right
there's one right here riding torch and
then we push them in wait a minute you
mean they've been committing genocide
for years against the uyghurs and they
gave them the ability to light the
opening flame to the all this
[ __ ] was the other even right she was
the opening
look at all that warmth on a cold chilly
night
good for china
don't worry they'll throw her in the
nuclear power plant cooling tower after
this and i think we'll be good to just
move on and uh they use by the way the
nuclear power plant the cooling tower
doubles as a slope for the slalom hill
so really multi-purpose uh
oriented here yeah orientals well at
least they uh they stopped the beatings
in the jail cells so that the uyghurs
could look and see that one of their own
was making it they didn't stop they more
so put it on paul like a pot well they
they went back together it was more like
they like simon says red light
green right green right
i didn't say simon says i don't need to
i beat you bang bang bang gosh this
place is terrible it's an awful awful
awful place yes it is and uh china's
reasoning for uh
some of this was because according to
the ccp xinjiang invented skiing
[Laughter]
you see this i know i followed that hill
yes exactly yeah i ski that was it
it just pushed a mongolian down the wall
well he didn't make it we told you keep
out oh look at that put some wood on his
feet no this is what they wrote
grew up in altay a perfect of prefecture
bordering mongolia in far northwest
xinjiang chinese officials consider the
region the cradle of alpine sport
after cave paintings were discovered
there of hunters on skis dated at 10 000
years old actually the world's old
skiing artifacts originate from no
surprise russia
not china
russia it's just this is the thing when
you just you lie so much i don't think
they were ready for the world stage
because it was like well that people
going that's a lie like well no one
calls us
i know we didn't expect that we could
say we venture skiing you say okay you
invented skiing and fireworks and
noodles and good more money
that wasn't the only tone deaf uh
torchbearer that they had lane just sent
me this they had another death well so
so we we brought this up a little bit
earlier we were talking about uh stones
being used as weapons of war yeah 20
indian soldiers were killed well one of
the torchbearers
was let me bring it up you got another
overlay here yeah
one of the torchbearers was this guy who
was one of the people killing the indian
soldiers
oh
was this his reward
great way for him to you know honor
their country they're just walking out
and knowing no one in china is like hey
that's isn't that the guy who was
killing the other guy yeah well he got
he murdered people and he got to light
the torch yeah it's the magic yeah
that's totally cool we should compete in
this yeah i remember with the walkout we
had george zimmerman playing the trumpet
why why do you feel honestly we should
compete
why do i feel that yes i think it's
important for us to compete in the
olympics no matter what the scenario to
some extent there may be some exceptions
to that but think about this in nazi
germany like communist china well jesse
owens goes doesn't that doesn't
this works jesse passes your litmus goes
there and actually beats the aryan race
in front of hitler and made a statement
it was fantastic we could have boycotted
that olympics but we chose to go in this
case what we need our companies to do is
not carry the water for china we need
our athletes to go and compete and do
well because this is the world watching
i'm just hoping before this ends there
are some taiwanese who pull them munich
yeah for sure and leave no no i mean
golem munich that's not what he did not
see that movie with eric banner no i did
see the movie i'm just trying to
understand the context you want them to
kill some you don't want them to kill
anyone no i want the taiwanese to kill
the chinese
yes yes yes yes
because i only know the movie yes
exactly he doesn't understand the
historical context i didn't read the
rich history so i guess for gerald the
only uh appropriate uh scenario where we
would not compete is if the actu if the
olympics were taking place in the actual
hotel rwanda that's right still that
it's because i think you still go yeah
yeah yeah just not for the winter
olympics
yeah exactly no i want the ioc not to
put the olympics in places like this
we've done russia a couple of but that's
the problem the ioc just like the u.n
it's not what it used to be the ioc is
now a political organization they're
looking for dollar bills baby just like
the ioc doesn't even require
transgender athletes to have undergone
one year of hormone replacement therapy
now now you just say what you are that's
it they say well we're leaving it to the
individual sports well do you leave it
to the individual sports for people to
take steroids well no no we'd have to
regulate that okay when testosterone is
injected directly into the ass however
we're a little murky on the rule book
the point is all they're doing is
acquiescing to social justice
international governments it's not the
same as when we went to no i know that
but what is what is what do you achieve
by not going so if we don't go they're
like okay fine whatever we don't care
obviously they're bowing down to china
anyway they don't care if the united
states goes we don't have the power that
we think we do with the ioc and the
athletes who have this much of a window
to compete
don't get to compete well if you do if
everyone boycotts china then the world
championships
but not everybody's going to do this we
can't even get germany to say that
they're going to cancel the freaking
pipeline to make sure russia doesn't
invade ukraine like we don't have the
backing because we have joe biden in
office i mean i didn't expect germany to
ever get it right well that's true if we
had trump in office i would agree
because he would take a hard line and he
would be like listen
geez so i don't know if you know but nbc
actually parroted and this is what i'm
talking about unlike jesse owens unlike
and if you guys don't know about this
let me just give you some context joe
lewis beating max uh schmeling
uh his second fight against schmeling is
probably one of the most consequential
athletic events
of all time maybe we can you guys can
actually find a video we can bring it up
later on mug club let me give you the
context for this and this is why you
know muhammad ali called joe lewis uh a
house negro he would use the term like
uncle tom because joe lewis was beloved
by the country uh and he he wasn't a
race baiter at all he was supported by
white fans and black fans alike and he
was undefeated except he had lost a
fight to max schmeling this german guy
and there was a fight between joe lewis
and max mulling a rematch and hitler was
really propping up max smelling right
this was going to be the ambassador for
the aryan race and joe lewis was the
american and the truth is they were
friends later on in life max schmeling
actually wasn't a nazi he just he didn't
really have a choice in the matter uh
but the president called joe lewis and
this was right before he was about to go
to war keep in mind joe lewis not a
draft dodger like muhammad ali um i
don't remember if he served or what he
was he was going to he said i'll answer
the call yeah and right before that
you're talking about not to during world
war ii the president called and said we
really need you to win this for
for the good guys yeah this is a guy the
only guy to have knocked out joe lewis
at this point
i think it was it was many many many
tens of millions it might have been like
100 million people whatever it was
everyone was tuned into it i think the
stadium was i don't remember the numbers
but it was something that would shock
you today way way way way bigger than
the super bowl joe lewis has all of this
pressure on his shoulders and he knocked
out max mellon the one guy who beat him
up this was a huge deal imagine i can't
imagine an athlete with more pressure on
his shoulders than joe lewis in that max
smelling tube out and it was a perfect
right hand that he threw was
unbelievable um i say that because
there's a different it was a different
time where the president was saying
you're one of our guys where the media
was right championing joe lewis saying
we really hope that our guy beats the
fascist beats the national socialist
whereas today you have nbc literally
parroting communist party talking points
during the open opening ceremony watch
yeah it's worth remembering that while
western countries may be boycotting
these olympics over human rights issues
china styles itself as a champion of the
developing world
and it has plenty of support in
countries from africa to latin america
where it's investments of building up
local economies
oh they're not genocidal they're they're
they're genocidal stylists
oh my god they style themselves well
yeah i guess if you consider uh saddling
uh developing countries with absolutely
unpayable debt to hopefully eventually
turn them into indentured servants which
by the way indentured servants still
exist in china yeah they're a champion
of the developing world yeah how can nbc
say that with a straight face yeah it's
altruistic by the way they're going into
these african and latin american
countries and making sure they buy up
all the rights to the minerals yeah so
that when apple wants to build their
next technological advancement they're
like you got to go through us we have
all the minerals in the world good luck
yeah
seriously that's what they're doing this
isn't altruistic they're not going to
help the world they're seeking a
financial interest in these countries
and having their way and trying to get
them by the short hairs by saddling them
with unpayable debt yes this is what
they want and let's kind of move on down
the list here too china's been lying
about events the events haven't been
fair this is also what's different
what's the problem is it's unfair
they're cheating and of course because
there's a complicit media who's afraid
to speak out against china they don't
call them on it let me give you a few
examples so china won multiple golds in
speed skating after some unbelievable
penalty calls so in the uh the 1k meter
semifinal south korean skater you knew
that guy wasn't going to win look
south korean and china jamaican bobsled
team can win so can he
if there was a south korean competing
and he set the world record by several
body lengths
they would have just said no because he
it was a ghost
so south korean skater world record
holder i want to make sure i get his
name right huang dai hyun and people say
i'm all racist for not getting it right
was disqualified here's the thing i
think we have a clip he was disqualified
well okay
i want you to watch it and see what the
south korean does but like i should get
the medal and he didn't
look at that
look at that
boom pulls ahead you saw that yeah
that's why he was disqualified because
he passed two chinese skaters he was uh
i think they're saying it was an illegal
pass right okay it would go past yeah
because we know chinese chinese chinese
folks know so much about passing have
you seen them in the left lane the point
is they have yeah
there's your ego pass what you pass
someone who's chinese
it's true it's like it just wasn't a
pile up in the middle of the aisle right
what why no it's an illegal pass be
because you passed chinese yeah you can
pass but can't pass chinese that is
unbelievable he has two chinese athletes
and they said it's illegal just because
they're chinese athletes i think they
said they crossed the blue and now you
put your hand down which is totally
legal from the last time i checked speed
skating in the final after crossing the
line first hungarian skater was
disqualified giving who what who the
gold china
oh
everything's coming up kami weird
and of course uh south korea they've
lodged an official complaint uh and an
appeal over the issue i'm sure yeah
they'll get right on that yeah the ioc
that gave it to communist china in the
first place is actually going to
overturn that right yes
oh no oh you're mad you you said we
broke ioc i would eat no they say it was
fair so you know
better rock next time
these world organizations won't even
acknowledge that taiwan's a country yeah
you think they're going to overturn a
medal now we don't have time for that
now we don't have time for this also we
need the money
so uh and then later the united states
speed skating uh they had a mixed relay
team uh-huh by that means mixed uh i
think means uh you know mixed uh uh uh
male and uh or uh i can't say male and
female
it's uh
i don't know
that's just it's safer to say
interracial
um the mixed relay team was disqualified
and that guess what happened
they switched parts well it allowed
someone to win the gold can you guys
guess who won the gold instead when they
were disqualified
china
he spoiled it
america got sick and in china
woo da jing couldn't bring it home in
third place
and shaolin said orleau
and the united states are going to the
gold middle match and the united states
have also been penalized as well
so that means
the two teams going through will be
hungry in china
oh
there you go
and the other hungarian person got
disqualified so it's like you know what
you win some you win some china oh my
gosh
and uh the american skater uh man benny
i think you have that right said
apparently one of our teammates crossed
the blue line and that made the chinese
team miss their exchange or something
like that it was an interesting call for
sure but it is what it is that means i
got screwed well he's going to get
killed if he says
and i i do love that you know what the
most amusing and we'll get to the
propaganda from the media there too by
the way that's just absolutely
terrifying but it shouldn't be all that
surprising uh the funniest response from
the biased refereeing was from a korean
reporter
uh lim beyonce i don't know if you wrote
this if you read this he wrote an entire
article with the same sentence repeated
10 times it just says
let's just give china all the medals
let's just give china all of the medals
that's all he wrote
it's ten times fair point like if this
is how it's gonna go where all these
things are just being judged by them
it's like okay fine we get it we get it
and i would say by the way all the
references are available at
littlecredit.com but that one was
scrubbed uh before it went viral so we
have screen shots but we can't actually
give you a link oh okay yeah i wonder
how that happened which brings us to our
next point
uh this dutch reporter so you know i
don't know if you know this but uh you
know
communist country the china well and
it's open and fair society for reporters
they can report on anything they want
yeah yeah yeah and uh and uh and covet
came from a bat well yes of course so um
there's a dutch reporter on air and
what's funny to me is he seems surprised
by this where he's dragged away by a
communist chinese goon mid
reporting they they don't even care here
it is
they're hurting him
oh my gosh fair open society brian with
weather
you know what the excuse for the chinese
they said no no his
location was too dingy ah oh so then you
put him at the ritz no revoke press pass
yeah yes send him to wiga camp yeah send
them to wigan camp sorry i mean uh super
fun adventure lane yeah the summer camp
slightly rashbeating right yes course
summer camp with no food or water yeah
good time mcmahon anti-fat camp
canoe
defense the propaganda arm is just
absolutely everywhere when you look at
the communist chinese party so let me
give you some examples here twitter had
to remove thousands of state-backed uh
chinese accounts now that would seem
like oh progress however they still have
allowed chinese state officials to be on
their platform like foreign ministry
spokesperson
i can't get it right posts gems like
this the uyghur ethnic group enjoys
equal rights and freedoms as the other
55 ethnic groups in china the u.s should
enact an african-american human rights
policy act instead of the uyghur human
rights policy act china of course
controls free speech not only in china
but in united states colleges by things
like the confucius institutes the ccp
spies we've talked about this they
actually do have ccp spice communist
chinese communist party spies here in
the united states every 10 hours the fbi
opens a new china-related investigation
and uh it's just it's it's it's it's a
non-stop it's a non-stop flow of
propaganda these people don't have the
american interests at heart they
actually want to see everything that you
know and love be destroyed and the only
person who was in office who spoke tough
and actually acted tough and got them to
act in line at all was president donald
trump
why do you think now that there's no
concern
it's for the same reason that north
korea is firing off rockets like the 4th
of july
because they see former vice president
[ __ ] pants and they go okay we're fine
please let that be his new name
i think it is it says it on his
bracelets look we're all lucky if it
stays in his pants okay they had to
clean the
the pope's room for an hour after he
left okay
you remember the bathroom incident that
delayed the pope yeah the rest of the
vatican thought the place was being
fumigated
just give me your hat oh please give me
your hat let me just
so this is one of the unintended
consequences of the left right now
parroting this lie this black lives
matter lie that black americans are more
likely to be shot by cops than white
americans and we've debunked that over
and over again do you see what our
enemies are quoting to us right now
right you worry about killing african
americans in your communities and we'll
worry about our problems right you're
giving comfort and aid to a potential
enemy at least economically an enemy
right now somebody who definitely does
not have our best interest at heart
because
you wanted to get the votes of a group
that's it right you just wanted some
votes you're willing to trade everything
that we believe in for votes so that you
can stay in power and do what you want
to do yeah how small is that that's what
the chat what the the chinese communist
party but they use for propaganda as
they just use the talking point former
vice president biden and colette harris
that's it that's it that's all they do
yeah and you and you have people who've
obviously been subjugated and they're
afraid to speak out of course in china
and it's a very different when people
talk about crime when people talk even
in japan where they talk about hey
there's less gun crime they can ban guns
there look it's a very very different
culture and the kind of stuff kind of
things that are happening in china would
not fly here in the united states why
precisely because of the kind of country
that created the first amendment and the
second amendment with
which former vice president joe biden
wants to do away with you just heard him
talking about that weapons of war this
is we are a time in this country where
international battle lines are being
drawn and i know it was a great idea at
one point that we are the world isn't
that great all hold hands
you can't hold hands with someone who
wants to commit genocide yeah
not once is committing genocide you
can't hold hands with someone who
doesn't believe in the freedom to hold
hands
and that's why i don't think that we
should be contributing i don't think
that we should be competing there i get
it it kind of it can hurt some athletes
but there are other ways for them to
compete i don't think the ioc is
something that should be honored
recognized or respected by the united
states anymore i think it's become a
joke and i think that china is uh is a
serious threat and i think it's one that
we could absolutely crush economically
if we had the fortitude to do so
and by the way if you're sitting out
there talking about social justice and
systemic racism there there should be no
one more enthusiastic
in this country based on the rhetoric
there should be no one in this country
more enthusiastic about crushing china
financially
than the liberals in the democratic
party yeah
systemic discrimination right justice
okay
why do you why do you want to be allies
with china why do you want uh tpp why do
you want nafta why was it donald trump
who believes in strong national borders
who doesn't believe that we have a
systemically racist country why was it
him who said we need to be tough on
china because they actually commit gross
human rights abuses why aren't you why
are you complaining about
non-rights violations here
and do nothing no i'm not saying you go
in and you police china you police the
world team america i get that you can't
do that but there are some easy things
to do like not sharing technology
like maybe not patronizing china like
maybe putting the tariffs on them
squeezing the financial advice on them a
little bit like making sure that their
spy apps aren't allowed like getting
like you know what swalwell start with
not banging chinese spies that would be
a good jumping off point the low bar and
even if you do use a jimmy hat we're not
asking a lot
well i love how the left just went
absolutely nuts when we said hey look
we're seeing a lot of muslim attackers
on american culture right now we're
seeing bombers and we're seeing stuff
around the world no we saw that and we
said hey maybe we should look at the
islamic religion and oh i can't believe
that you would say this about them
they're being killed right now in china
they're being interned at the very least
and rights taken away in beatings and
we're coming to their defense right
where are you
jake tapper finally comes to the party
and says something with the olympics
launch where have you been and by the
way though that also tells you something
the reason that they're being oppressed
that way in china is and i'm not saying
of course we should do that anywhere
else i think it's horrible i think you
should be free to practice any religion
but they do understand and recognize
china a communist regime a distinctly
atheist communist regime that islam is
not like christianity islam is not like
jobs witnesses it's not like mormons
it's not like buddha take your pick
insert it here uh it is a prescription
for a political ideology and they see
that as a threat to their political
system that's why they are much harsher
on uyghurs than they are i mean they're
harsh in pretty much anyone who
practices religion but they're not
committing mass genocide to that level
so that should also again
just raise some eyebrows why is china
looking this way at islam because they
have to maintain maintain control and
islam does say look this is how you
establish
a an islamic government that's different
there is no way to establish a christian
government no because someone reads a
bible verse when they go and speak in
the senate floor is not the same thing
so i think we do need to recognize the
warning signs that they see and also
understand that of course they're an
absolutely awful horrible country uh
with whom we should have nothing to do
with at this point and i want you to
comment below what your thoughts here
are in china what your thoughts are on
the olympics if you do think we should
compete if you don't i i don't i don't
think we should have anything to do with
it because we're at a different point in
history specifically because of the ioc
specifically also because of the way the
media is covering this we have no allies
on the side of freedom with these
international events that's the problem
on the flip side though um even though
this has been a huge propaganda campaign
the chinese you know
the topography is something really
special it is a beautiful backdrop there
in the yeah
it's a beautiful place hey we've got
some cooling towers it looks like a
water park in front of the simpsons
intro yeah let's put the ski jump there
you sure about that
no yeah they're going to sign on to the
paris accord they'll get right on that
it's just
this is is that those are nuclear
uh coolers right why didn't they just
this is the issue is they're just not
used to any form of accountability that
they didn't even realize you know what
we're gonna see those
i don't know if you know this but we can
see that
they're highlighted no no no no no no no
no like uh
blazing saddles just fake town behind it
is beautiful mountain
then why don't you just show us a
beautiful mountain to uh troll you off
cent
the internment camp is right behind that
so we had to make sure he couldn't the
olympics are a perfect microcosm of when
people talk about china becoming the
next great superpower yeah if you let
them cheat
if they just ban people if they just
they just disqualify people who beat
their team yeah and make up some rule
it's the same thing when we're dealing
with international diplomacy when we're
dealing with with geopolitical issues
specifically fiscally economically if
you just allow them to cheat if you just
allow them to to devalue the if you just
allow them to put tariffs on what comes
in and not what goes out if you just
allow them to take advantage of the
american economic system and steal
intellectual property well sure they can
become a great superpower the good thing
is we can do a lot about that now to
stop it you can look at the concrete
policies from donald trump and you can
look at how they play differently under
donald trump they're right back to their
old tricks
under the people who are supposed to get
everyone accountable on the paris accord
right under the new party who's supposed
to get everyone to play ball with
international climate change agreements
and they're worse than ever
all right look uh we actually have uh
coming up here in a little a little bit
but i want to play this clip because
you know our next guest senator ted cruz
has not only talked about the uh issues
with big tech uh quite a bit in the past
and he's spearheading some some bills
there which i hope will actually you
know be fruitful but um
more importantly we want to talk about
the gofundme situation because this has
been a big deal with canada and it could
be mirrored in the united states it has
been mirrored in the united states
there's this leaked zoom call i want to
show this before we bring them on uh it
revealed that the mayor of ottawa
the mayor of ottawa was responsible
for the gofundme of the freedom convoy
truckers in canada 10 million dollars
being pulled down here's the video we
have through the efforts of deputy bell
christian hino
the mayor and his staff we've been able
to shut down the go funding program
that's a temporary reprieve because the
funds are already moving in different
directions
we are now going after supply and fuel
coming into the area through
investigations and intelligence
operations and interdictions all of
which were underway yesterday fully
underway today well it's not a violation
of first amendment if a company does
whatever it wants why don't you go build
your own gofundme so here to talk about
that and more is senator ted cruz
[Music]
all right he is the host of verdict
podcast you can find him on the twitter
at sen
ted cruz uh senator cruz how are you sir
thanks for being here
stephen i'm doing fantastic are you
you're in the great state of texas and
i'm not you're doing better than i am
well thank you very much and you but you
have that depth of field thing going on
there it's like you have uh like you
have darren aronofsky uh using your
webcam what do you that's pretty cool
uh you know it it's all smoke and
mirrors now oh okay all right well that
makes sense
i'm actually in the same green screen
room where we fake the moon landing yes
that makes perfect sense uh and uh where
they also have these slalom slopes for
the communist chinese olympic games so i
want to go back to that i i will admit
it was really great seeing skiers
filming blade runner i mean
right yes that's actually by the way new
blade runner is better than the old
blade runner people can change my mind
uh although it's great if you don't have
ambien on hand the original blade runner
have now
have you seen that uh the video with the
mayor of ottawa who just admitted and
actually took pride uh in the fact that
he was responsible for this gofundme
being taken down for people who don't
know 10 million raised for these freedom
convoy truckers not one act of violence
committed according to the police not
one act of violence committed entirely
peaceful protest this mayor just bragged
about getting the gofundme taken down
have you seen that yet
so i just heard you play it a second ago
i had not heard it before then but look
what's going on
in canada number one stop for a second
it is amazing it is a phenomenal
ground swell
that that this freedom convoy is
happening canadians if there's one thing
about canadians they're nice they're
nice they're polite
um
and hear you
driving into town honking they're pissed
off
because the government is trying to
force them to get back mandates to get
vaccines against their wishes now my
view i'm pro-vaccine i'm vaccinated but
i believe in individual liberty it's
your damn choice whether you want to get
a vaccine if you want to get a vaccine
great knock yourself out if you don't
great knock yourself out it ought to be
your choice and and the canadian
truckers who are standing up
they are fighting
against
government tyranny and fighting not just
for canadians they're fighting for
americans and and pause for a second let
me get to the gofundme thing in a second
but pause for a second and think about
just the phenomenon this reminds me
uh of the f joe biden chance at football
games
that that it is spontaneous football
stadiums all across the country you know
when when when f joe biden really had
fight
with a new england patriots game in
boston
the entire stadium was chanting
what is now known as let's go brandon
but it was in in the original latin so
to speak yes
it's a reflection of of collective
outrage
at the arrogance and abuse of the petty
parents and government who believe they
can make these health care decisions for
you now
take it and put it on steroids not only
do do these
government tyrants believe they can
force you to make the health care
choices they want you to make now
10 million dollars given through
gofundme to fund and help support these
truckers and what happens
these government officials go to big
tech and say hey
would you steal that money would you
number one
take the 10 million dollars that was
given for the canadian truckers don't
give it to them
but number two
give it to your own shipping cost right
i decided gosh steven i i want to take
all the money in your bank account uh
and i want to give it to to whatever
groups i support
that would be called theft
you would be prosecuted for stealing
someone else's money in this world big
tech is all all the happy to be the head
men for government or in some cases it
would be called marriage but you know
taking it to the kate spade store from
the account but uh yes no i agree with
you entirely and it's actually
the exact inverse of robin hood where a
lot of people say robin hood stole from
the rich and gave to the poor no robin
hood stole from the corrupt government
that had over taxed its citizens and
gave it back to the people right now
what we are seeing is the government
going to go fund me which is meant to
fund me right just like youtube the
whole idea is it's personal the little
guy going to go fund me and saying hey
we're going to steal that money and then
distribute it to charities of our choice
who no doubt will of course support
leftist causes which is a proxy
basically a glorified pack right black
lives matter chaz chop liberal party of
canada uh and only when there was
pressure put on them did they stop now i
i saw that you drafted a letter um to
the federal trade commission if i'm not
mistaken about gofundme and the canadian
convoy do they have that right
no that's exactly right calling on the
ftc to investigate gofundme for
deceptive trade practices because look
they've launched this site they say if
you give money you can give it to to the
causes whatever the gofundme is when
they turn around and steal that money or
try to steal that money that's a
deceptive trade practice and in this
instance they ultimately backed down
because the public outcry was so great
but they tried to steal 10 million
dollars and and
listen can i start from a principle
that any
big collection of power is wrong and is
dangerous whether it is an enormous
collection of power in government an
enormous collection of power in in
silicon valley that the accumulation of
power is a threat to our individual
liberty and what we're seeing here it's
a pattern we're seeing
these petty authorities by the way covet
has unmasked these guys that they want
to control every aspect of your life
they want you fired they want you
silence you must be masked vaccinated
and and the next thing you know they're
going to be doing probes i don't even
want to know what the next thing is but
but but
these are people who believe they have
the power to control every aspect of
your life and then the their goons and
so wait a second you haven't been probed
i thought that was the more effective
swab
well it is how the chinese do covet
testing but that's a separate issue well
yeah and also the secretary of
transportation
[Laughter]
right well the problem is that's where i
keep my spare keys so i was like put
them back uh no do you have they gotten
back to you by the way the the ftc
what's what's her name over there um the
chairwoman uh is it uh lena um lena khan
did she get back to you
they have not yet although i just sent
the letter uh day before yesterday well
two days seems like something they
should get on i mean come on what else
are they doing it's a theft of 10
million dollars
what do they have to steal the hope
diamond
uh well just don't tell me where you
just where you store the hope diamond
yeah well i think
one guess
[Laughter]
oh no did oh did we lose him all right
well look hold on we're gonna we're
gonna clarify this caller because he's
drafted up a bill for big tech uh and
we'll bring him back on here on the mug
club uh if you're watching on youtube
right now smash that like button we're
gonna be here uh on mug club with ted
cruz where it'll be on censored youtube
youtube i think you know what to do
right now do it youtube
foreign